[Applause]
welcome to lawrence jones cross country
we will be coming to you live tonight
and every saturday night
this show will take you to the front
lines of america's biggest challenges
we'll give you a front row seat to the
biggest stories sports and entertainment
we'll bring you exclusive interviews
that you won't see anywhere else
this nation has a lot of challenges
crime the border covet the list goes on
and on and on
but make no mistake
we'll also find a way to provide you
with plenty of reasons to smile
because in these tough times sometimes
you just need a moment to breathe
and with that
let's go cross country
[Music]
on this inaugural edition of cross
country we will be on the ground in both
los angeles and houston as the nation
attempts to cope with a historic crime
wave
in just a few minutes you will meet a
mother of a 16 year old daughter who was
gunned down shot 22 times
while walking her dog the dog came home
but she didn't
the accused killer is back on the street
here's a quick look
my brother said let's take her to the
hospital and when i
when i tried
to pick her up i just knew that
she wasn't going to make it and
i i just rather i told my brother there
was nothing we can do and i just started
my daughter that
that i loved her a lot and
that i loved her
before we take you to that horrific
scene in houston we're investigating the
tragic results that are happening when
progressive da's
let violent offenders back on the street
and many americans are asking
is america becoming a country where we
put criminals before victims
sometimes it takes one case to help us
change course
that's what brought me to los angeles to
meet with the sheriff of the county the
deputy district attorney
the story of brianna kepler
let's make it personal
there's been stories all across the
country even l.a of victims that are
being killed shot stabbed
and there's no justice for them at all
you got brianna
and that story
touches the heart of the entire country
the guy that did it had a rap sheet mr
smith
and he was allowed to be back on the
street why
well simple because every single time he
gets arrested they play down the case
to next to nothing doesn't mean that
crime didn't happen but every single
time there's a question about
prosecution
law enforcement did their job they made
the arrest put the case together
presented to the d.a in every single
circumstance and all those different
states and every time it was all let's
bargain it down to something as if
somehow that advances the cause of
justice it doesn't it allows someone
like smith to continue
victimizing the community until the
point he commits one that's uh
too far and her name on tragically
brianna kupfer
so you got mr smith with a long red rap
[ __ ] if you go and you look at his
his shots you know the mug shots
they're different ones
they're consistent but there was never
anything that said hey i've been
reformed i should be back out there in
society sheriff can i take you back to
the crime scene of what has been
released to the public of him
going through the alley
making his way
to brianna she sends a text message
about 13 minutes before and says
she feels a little eerie about this
something is a little weird she has a
feeling there he then murders her in
cold blood stabs her
he leaves that scene goes back through
the alley goes to the 7-eleven gets a
vape has a 30-minute conversation
acts like nothing's happened
does that matter
how you prosecute a person like that
when you see how cold-blooded they can
be
i would hope for a
deputy district attorney that is on
their game that that will definitely
matter to show just the depravity of the
crime the wantedness of it and it was
like as casual taking the dog out for a
walk
nothing and the fact that he went door
to door
visiting several places until he wound
up
in her establishment by herself
a crime of opportunity should the
citizens in los angeles or any major u.s
city feel safe
well in terms of the law enforcement
side are you know the men in uniform be
it blue tanning green whatever the
uniform is across the entire nation
they're working hard look at what
happened to the two nypd officers doing
the lord's work out there answering the
call and they paid tragically with their
lives so
they're out there cops throughout our
nation are doing their job
where the wheels are falling off when it
comes to the prosecution side you're a
democrat yes
gascon is a democrat
are you really a democrat then oh i'm a
democrat but i'm a democrat uh what was
considered the blue dog democrat of the
old days of jfk of fdr
but this progressive wing of the
democratic party has gone so far to the
left
that they've literally left everyone in
the middle
moderates
both on the conservative liberal side
like
where'd they go
and extremism in either side on the far
right or the far left is bad
it doesn't advance the public's interest
it doesn't resolve
the pressing issues of today which
violent crime we need to have smart
people in office they're going to do the
right thing for the right reasons and
these ultra progressive da's with their
agenda are definitely not that how does
it make you feel that gascon was a
former cop
it's i mean is that something in the law
enforcement community a guy that wore
the badge
that had people under his command just
like you
i mean there's a lot of cops that don't
want to do the job anymore because of
da's like him but he used to worry about
he knows what you guys go through on a
day-to-day basis so how do you
square the two
well he claims that you know that he was
doing the wrong thing that he had to
change your heart or something i don't
buy that whatsoever he knows exactly
what's going on in the streets he knows
what
the organized criminal elements and
multi-generational gangs
he knows what they're getting away with
and what their
whole reason to be is
so pretending somehow that he had a
change of heart no he had george soros
funding
and he's just following that agenda
because that's what put him in office
bankrolled him you know i've always said
and this is my final question to you
that
if you really want to stop this crime
you need three things you need the
police chiefs to sheriff that's your law
enforcement angle you got to have your
d.a at the table but you also need a
judge that's going to sign on these
warrants to get these bad guys
from your point of view what do you
think it's going to
take to stop the bleeding today we want
if you had full control
you're on national news right now to
tell the public if i want to stop all
this crime in the country right now this
needs to happen what would you tell them
we need three things to happen actually
zero bail schedule needs to be thrown
out
off the bat
prop 47 which laid the foundation for
decriminalizing so many things needs to
be thrown out or rewritten entirely it
was just it blew up in everyone's face
the author of prop 47 is our d.a george
gascon
and then he took that
and doubled down on stupid and then
decided not to prosecute hardly anything
so now we have all three of those
elements they need to be changed what do
you think about the state of your city
right now
well we're in a crisis right now at
least when it comes to public safety
and other health related affairs
we have rising crime especially
homicides
a lot of shootings we have homelessness
everywhere
it's not a good time in los angeles
you deal with a lot of big crimes
yes
what is your perception of your boss the
d.a
well i think our my boss has uh
implemented a lot of bad ideas uh in the
last year that he's been the district
attorney
he has implemented policies that he
calls criminal justice reform but it
really amounts to nothing more than
decarceration efforts
he is not charging
obvious crimes
he is advocating on behalf of people to
be released from prison sooner than they
should
he is not meeting with victims he's not
allowing da's to attend parole hearings
he's under charging offenses including
violent offenses not charging special
allegations special circumstances
everything he's doing is aimed at
reducing the prison in jail populations
has nothing to do with helping people
has nothing to do with transforming
lives does not have anything to do with
helping to uplift lower economic
underserved communities
he's masquerading it that way but it has
nothing to do with that effort at all so
you're taking him on in the sense of
you're speaking for the people that you
swore enough to protect
what's been the response from the d.a to
have it's not just you there's other
deputy da's as well that have been
outspoken for sure
are you gonna lose your job
i don't think so uh we have we're well
protected here in los angeles county we
have certain civil service protections
when i speak out against him or really
against his policies
i guess my big question is is he
upholding
state and federal law right now no
absolutely not
our district attorney is nullifying
important laws and he's doing it
explicitly and unapologetically he's not
charging special circumstances he's not
charging gun allegations he's not
charging gang allegations he eviscerated
the
gang unit that we had to suppress gang
crime wise county
because he wants to see fewer people go
to jail in prison and he wants to let a
lot of the ones who are already in there
out before they've been properly
rehabilitated
you just got signed a big case that you
can't talk about brianna
and it really touched the heart of the
country
do you think
that is a turning point because when you
put a face on it
it seems like the reaction from the
public is is much different and when you
have someone that hunted her down
essentially cased it
she
feel for her life she texts her friend
do you think that may be the recipe to a
lot of this is highlighting the stories
over and over again well i think that's
what you all need to do in the media
certainly we're trying to do it from the
public service end
you know we don't want to make it
political
but when people see this they want to
recall the district attorney
and there's been names that should
challenge the district attorney and
you're at the top of that list oh
who says that
what the people say
uh well i'm flattered by that and you
know i i have been in this office for
over 20 years i love what i do i'm
committed to public service i'm
committed to working on the interests of
the people and then victims as well if
the recall happens
and the voters say they need someone
that they trust
that has a proven track record of
fighting for the victims and not the
criminals would you accept that call
i certainly hope to be in position to
accept that call if that happens
he's going to watch this interview
i know he does because he's watched all
the other interviews and they often
release the statement so with him
watching right now since
he doesn't take meetings with you or
anything and
you speak for victims you speak for a
lot of your colleagues that feel like
they don't have the necessary support
d.a is watching right now what would you
tell him
what i would tell him is
sit down and let's have a conversation
first and foremost
as the district attorney
why aren't you committed to following
the law will you follow the law
where do you find the authority
to ignore the law
because if district attorney gascon were
following the law if he were doing
everything under the law that he could
to make us safe he would be in a much
better position right now because
he could go before the people and say
crime is going up but i'm fighting for
you
i'm pulling no punches
i'm doing everything the law allows to
keep this community safe he can't do
that
i defy him to do that go out get
proximate with the people
stand before them and fix your lips mr
d.a to say that you're doing everything
in your power to keep this community
safe
wow hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else